Cái hoài hoạt động kiểm tra giám xác việc cho thành quy định của phó lột về tiêu trình quy trình
ví thuật nó lượng và trước lượng sản phẩm hàng hóa lối với sản xí ông Embery trong hoạt động
sản xóa phó trế phân phối, lưu thông trên thị trường, kịt thời phát hiện ngăn chẳng và xử
lý theo thông quyền phó kính nghĩ, câu quan có thông quyền xử li hàng BB phạm
quy trình ký thuật về phá trế rất lượng nhìn liệu, hàng BB kinh ruang sản xí học Embery
không phủ hợp quy trình ký thuật không đúng tiêu trình cũng bỏ áp giúc không bảo đảm yêu cầu về đò lượng
trước lượng và điều kịt lưu thông, lối tưởng kịm tra là các thường nhân phân phối sản xấu
tổng đại lý, đại lý, thương nhân nhận quyền bản lệ và cửa hàng bản lệ sản xấu
có kinh ruang mặt hàng xong xí học Embery, chương hợp cần thiết, căng cứ yêu cầu quan li nhà nước hoặc theo
để nghiệp của cơ quan có thông quyền phạm BB kinh tra có thể được mở giọc lối với các tổ chức
các bạn nhấn, có hoạt động bảo quan phân phối, lưu thông sản xí học Embery, nhằm đảm bảo công tác quan li cho lượng đặt kiệu quả
cảm nhất, nổi dung kìm tra bao gồm việc các cơ quan chuyên môn tiến hàng ra soát, các nhận dành xách các tổ chức, các bạn nhấn trong trối cùng sản xấu trên địa bản,
có hoạt động liên quan đến xong xí học Embery, gồm cơ sở sản xấu, phá trẻ, khó, tổng khó, khó chùi chuyển, thương nhân phân phối,
thông đại li, đại li, thương nhân quyền bản lệ và cửa hàng bản lệ xong xấu có kinh gió anh sẵn sình học Embery.